[ __ ] is this
yeah-uh skin ah Winston water when you
need it I can't believe this
people think I'm ugly
you ugly you're ugly baby pie is so old
and ugly
oh you look ugly AF please shame ugly
why are you so ugly PewDiePie is so ugly
my hands have are so ugly please kill me
thank you
I'm going
[Music]
why does everyone think I'm ugly is it
my gigantic nose it's a mine flayed and
ego this is my disgusting unattractive
personality wait a minute what is this
look at all these attractive people look
at the beautiful I'll never be this
beautiful why was I born with this
Swedish face beautiful absolutely
stunning so cute so cute ah 18 18 18
[ __ ] Oh Ryan after Beckham huh right
after Becca hey why am I not number one
how vain is 91 and pewdiepie is 18 what
the [ __ ] is this cuz then you look like
[ __ ] 18 huh
PewDiePie 18 xD XD XD for [ __ ] sake
okay that's right haters I'm [ __ ]
beautiful
and you know I get it you guys you guys
get jealous oh how you look I get it but
you know I have many talents not beyond
my beautiful face I'm joking
okay not really at all I'm not joking
alright so I realize that you guys may
need a little bit of help and you know
I'm pretty good with Photoshop so I'll
take some requests I'll try and help you
guys feel better about yourself because
I want you to feel just as fulfilled and
as a as I as I am I want to satisfy you
bros let's go PewDiePie give me a mouth
ok well that should be easy
[Music]
Wow that that looks so good
you're welcome I don't know why you
didn't have a mouth but now you do just
don't eat that per se
[Music]
Peter pipe make me emo
all right I can do that
all right done all right we're done here
roasting all right what else do we got
my dream is to look like a washing
machine
okay that can be arranged
[Music]
all right then we just gotta make it
real big make a real real pop Oh God
[Music]
we are there you go your washing machine
you're welcome I make people's dream
come true damn it I think you look way
better before make me into tentacle porn
please fine fine
all right you know I wouldn't criticize
other my fans physically her parents but
I these eyebrows they look like a
racetrack
[Music]
the Canada reminds me of the eyebrows of
Brock should they connect I think they
should
[Music]
your freckles though does remind me they
remind me a little bit of an octopus you
know they have the same kind of octopus
skin texture her wish was in fact to be
a tentacle porn so who am i to rob her
of that privilege
[Music]
okay there you go your tentacle porn you
just get the [ __ ] out now [ __ ] sake
disgusting no that's how she looked like
I forgot make Phil more beautiful oh
wait you can he's perfect
oh I'm sorry it's Phil I ranked 18 on
2060s list didn't think so
I fell you want to be beautiful I'll
make you beautiful I'll make you [ __ ]
gorgeous
[Music]
oh no why did you know schoo fell huh
why did he go uh fill more like no space
whoa oh no oh oh damn dog
damn those are some nostrils main do
where you get those nostrils done I
think we should move on make
jacksepticeye look better err he already
looks better than you anyways
oh I'm sorry's jack on the top topless
I don't think so alright let's see what
we can do jack
[Music]
cute kept I would [ __ ] that guy in the
ass it's so cute
all right makes me cringe so [ __ ]
weird whoops
top burner on and Dale at ease
my name is
okay sorry got a little sidetracked
there again your face on kazoo kid's
body
oh the kazoo kid which I'm apparently
look like yeah I'll prove that I'm not
the kazoo kid once and for all
[Music]
wait a minute Oh oh my
[Music]
yeah
no no it can't be it can't be oh my god
I've been suppressing the memories for
so long oh my god I could have forgotten
where I came from my roots I am
Kisuke I will always be kazoo kid and
I'm proud of me damn it
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys
since pulse is dead now please I'm
taking over the channel again please
check out the video over here for more
videos
so I can get Ad cents for prototype if
you enjoyed this video I guess and I'll
see you in the next one goodbye now
goodbye but bye bye bye bye